for that final to face yana pomnyacci
the bar is slightly over to his side
it's a must-win situation for our temi
of any chances for him
yes it's still early days in this game
only on move five and uh black already
has played something a bit rare bringing
the black queen out very early trying to
create a pin towards the white king and
uh this is known i've actually played
similar ideas myself but it does take
it does involve a bit of risk for black
and that's what artemis needs to do he
must win with black and uh
therefore he has to play
kind of maybe not the openings he would
usually choose so we see black grabber
pawn in the center white knight going
over to attack the black queen kicking
it away so the white can recapture in
the center with a pawn magnus just wants
a solid symmetrical pawn structure and
that will guide him towards the drawer
he requires but artemis will try and
find ways if he can of imbalancing
things
it's not going to be easy
easy though with the the
white pawns in the center i mean
the most principal idea there is
actually to be
to copy for black you know you establish
a pawn in center black will also do the
same but then the the margin for drawing
becomes considerably higher
yeah definitely i mean magnus is so good
at taking the game into kind of position
he wants to get it into and uh he's
played this opening not pushing the
pawns too far
you could say to to get a very safe
position uh the bishops both fearing
chateau very symmetrical there and um i
think it's going to be a really hard
task um for vladislav to to get anything
out of this game
um you know in some ways i'm kind of
happy because i want to see i want to
see magnus play yan in the final yeah i
want to see the repeat there and
obviously that's you know it's
going to be interesting to see how they
get on and i think i think yan just
playing on instinct there is very
understandable um you know as well and
uh
but still jan magnus is going to be
special
yeah and uh once black moves the queen
out of the way pawn takes pawn it's
going to be symmetrical pawn structure
and as you mentioned simon it's very
very likely at this point with the
symmetrical pawn structure magnus will
get to draw and we'll see that big final
yeah the dream final
yeah
definitely and uh okay in this game six
moves and our time is already down to 12
minutes why is this a position where
they're spending a lot more time what is
uh what is it about this position on
this opening i guess he's just trying to
get magnus out of his comfort zone
artemia is not playing the usually
recommended moves look at that black
queen on the edge of the board
one thing we teach beginners is don't
bring your queen out too early the queen
is the most valuable piece any time
she's attacked it'll be by a lower
ranked piece and she'll have to run away
she'll have to retreat and already that
black queen has moved twice i don't
really know what she's doing there she
looks very vulnerable to future threats
and i'll tell him if he's just trying to
confuse magnus maybe so that's why he's
been spending a few minutes on the clock
and i expect to see him do that over the
next five ten moves as well uh it would
be easy for atemive to try and find ways
to imbalance it and if he doesn't
imbalance things in the next
few moves then magnus will be super
solid and it won't be possible to beat
him
he's gonna have to take risks uh tammy f
um maybe that involves just uh
perhaps not pushing his queen spawn two
two squares forward maybe pushing it one
square forward
um but i don't really don't like the
fact that the black queen is stuck there
on the edge of the board i mean she's
out there on a limb what's she doing and
i don't see any possibility for her to
kind of comfortably get back into a
relevant position
and we mentioned this is a very very
rare opening ivanka has this been played
before no has this been seen before no
no i mean
it had been seen before up until this uh
unorthodox queen move okay so the first
new move already on move six that's rare
yeah i mean how often do you see a
novelty or a brand new position on move
six at a top level game that's good i
mean that's what he needs to do so he's
he's
trying you know
it's very hard to try against magnus
though i mean it's especially with black
especially so hard i mean
yeah the only person who managed to
unsettle magnus in this kind of
particular situation was actually wesley
so everyone else you know magnus has
been ruthless in closing down the game
and people have been forced to take
ridiculous amount of risks and of course
it's all backfired on them yeah we
should mention magnus has lost a few
games i think three games with white so
far in this tournament but most of them
were due to pressing too hard or taking
big risks and in a situation where he
only needs a draw it's going to be hard
uh it's going to be very difficult to
unsettle him we've seen this before he's
been in world championship matches for
example against anad only needed a draw
with white to settle things and he
achieved it
yeah i mean i'm thinking if i had the
white pieces
what you do with your d-pawn i mean the
most
aggressive move is to push it forwards
but i i i will bet anyone that he won't
play for booth little bet there anyone
want to take it on
brave enough i think you're right i
think you're right i i would not attack
the knight push it on get a fret
normally aggressive
i might be tempted to do something like
that because i love putting my horns on
the d5 square
however there's no need there's no need
to lengthen the black um diagonal of the
bishop i don't need to do that i can
just simply develop a knight keep the
position
all kind of solid yeah and i think it's
about control
yeah about controlling the position and
this is what we're talking that the
great players can do they can decide
what position they want and just take it
that way and pushing the pawn on i mean
i'd probably play that in 90 of the
games you know
without thinking because i like
attacking things and i like getting
space but the more sensible magnus move
here would just be like something like
e3 push the pawn to defend that pawn
silence there you go
that was that was good commentators kind
of not curse what's your curse
uh blessing yeah that's the
commentator's luck
yeah commentator's blessing so yeah i
mean that's much more magnus move though
but yeah just to not give anything for
black so far and we can explain just why
uh you called that move and why we were
not taking your bet simon in this
position the pawn is under fire and
maybe the strongest move maybe the most
natural move is to push forward gaining
time against this knight gaining space
but with great space does come great
responsibility and magnus in a must draw
situation where i mean where he only
needs the half point doesn't need to
take risks opening up this bishop
instead he pushes this pawn forward as
you mentioned solidifying this
rock-solid center and not only that but
he's bringing his knight out we talked
about whoops not that square we talked
about the queen sorry and white's knight
is going towards it almost trapping it
already so uh yeah this black queen is
going to go on a further journey further
adventure to try and run away from the
white knights
and uh to me it's looking very pleasant
for white even if black gets his pieces
out i'm looking at these bishop this
bishop this rook even if they come into
the game how are you ever going to break
down white's rock-solid center and
white's bishop here is also fantastic on
this diagonal controlling so many
squares i mean i i would have thought if
you're it's very hard to do but if
you're in a must-win situation the first
the first thing you should try and do is
uh make the pawn structure unsymmetrical
because when it's a symmetrical pawn
structure like we have here they're
facing off against each other there's
more likelihood it's gonna lead to equal
positions but if you have an
unsymmetrical uh unbalanced pawn
structure you have a more dynamic game
so that's maybe something that art you
know that vladislav has done done wrong
at the start of this game okay he's
played some really weird moves which is
understandable but actually the pawn
structure is not the kind of pawn
structure he'd want in a must must win
situation yeah it's hard to achieve any
kind of imbalance here right even if for
example you get a pawn structure like
this one uh white castling and black
pushing forward this is complete
symmetry and at the very best black can
hope for a draw most likely it's even
hard to achieve this to be honest even
though it might be the best and the most
solid
uh
kind of continuation so yeah this white
knight is just going to move over and
attack the black queen and gain even
more time for white
there we go it does happen after black's
castled the white knight has shuffled
across black's queen only has one safe
square i think has to go back this way
if it goes
in this direction it might get hit by
the white bishop at some point and it
might be even more trouble actually you
could maybe use this square but either
way no safety for the black queen yet
yeah i'm just losing so many moves so
many tempe yes uh i agree and uh
well
we are we're very interested in hearing
everyone's chess thoughts so if you do
have a question or chess suggestion then
please do tweet us using the hashtag
chesschamps and we'll try and answer
them on the show and talking about
questions jack allen has a question for
me he says they love the commentating
team
when what a tournament question
uh what a tournament question why does
ivanka refer to ranks and files on the
board as rows
and uh there is a reason i do that
because uh the chesapeake is to refer to
the the horizontal lines as ranks and
the vertical lines as uh files but okay
to a beginner who perhaps doesn't know
the game this might be a little bit
confusing so that's why i say rose
because then everyone knows
and i use the word lines so it's just to
make the game a little bit more
accessible yeah and it's also why we
have a lot of
expressions yeah and a lot of fun on the
show and try to stay away from notation
at least when we cannot show on the
board
because it can be a little confusing
with the notation yeah i mean you hear
like uh i was about to say you hear
lines like lines you hear words like
lines uh in other sports so it's just
maybe easier for people to understand in
general yeah and kyle got a question for
you as as you've been on the panel um
doing your job listening to the experts
yeah have you found your chess play has
shot up have you been learning
a lot
i have been learning a lot and what i am
noticing is that i'm recognizing
patterns so much easier and i'm also a
lot quicker when playing the opening
because i just know what to go for go
for center go for king safety and
develop my pieces so i just play faster
and i can maybe
recognize a few more openings yeah so
definitely yes i have gotten a lot
better but i'm still
far away from you guys yes and simon
there was a famous moment last season
when kaia spotted the best move and we
were struggling i don't think we would
have spotted it
you guys are doing a great job there are
teachers
exactly yeah
okay favorite moment from last season
yes and uh meanwhile magnus carlsen
the computer doesn't approve of what
he's doing but it looks very solid to me
at least he's offering a queen trade and
if the queen's come off
it looks like full safety for white okay
i mean while artemia finding a sneaky
way to allow the queen trade but at
least develop his pieces in the process
so if white goes and plays quintet's
queen capturing the black queen black's
bishop will recapture and at least it
will stand on a great diagonal
magnus looking very relaxed though
meanwhile leaning back
yeah he's nearly horizontal so i have a
question for you guys if you were in
magnus issues would you just trade off
queens
um i'm thinking about that i mean i'd
like to exchange the queens and then get
rid of this or move my bishop back or
something i'm thinking but i'd have to
have a concrete
reason because my king's stood in the
middle i have to be a little bit careful
with black's knight coming towards my
queen side so um i'd think about it i
mean i i wouldn't rush the decision here
to capture that queen personally
you do mention the big okay he hasn't
taken it yet but the big threat in the
position would be for black to jump in
with the knight
to check on this square or this square
and uh some real annoyances so maybe
white here would have had to drop a
bishop back
you lose a bit of time wow the
evaluation bar shooting up in black's
favor that is surprising so in the
current position if we go to it white
didn't go for the queen trade maybe he
should have done
instead just moving his bishop and has
this allowed black an opportunity can
black for example oh i was going to
suggest a very risky move which i don't
think works i was going to say jump in
with the knights but then it does allow
white to capture this rook in the corner
i don't think there's enough
compensation here for black what could
the downside be
i don't see it personally why is the
evaluation bar so excited about black's
position
simon no i i i can't say it either
generally if you can't see it i can't
see it david
let's just make that clear
um i don't see a problem with this
position at all really i mean uh
symmetrical
uh white's got
development is it bishop a6 here is that
the only thing it must be putting that
bishop on that diagonal and then
stopping the white king from castling
the white king stuck in the center
having to defend this knight in front of
it
and actually maybe no safe squares for
this knight either okay this has
happened on the board if the white
knight jumps this way as we mentioned
black's knight is going to leap in at
some point with some really annoying
checks on this square or this square
and instead magnus has moved his bishop
but this bishop
it just looks ugly it looks like a big
pawn staring against its own uh
fortified pawn structure there but it
wasn't a good piece i mean that was
going to make that point and that the
dark square bishop and white house is
kind of
trapped
by its own pawns and there wasn't
that much of a future for it yeah i have
noticed when analyzing similar types of
positions from this exact opening
actually that uh
computers do tend to evaluate this
structure very much in black's favor
so usually that's with a pawn in the
center and it's completely symmetrical
but this knight is currently dominated
by this pawn so maybe it will take white
just longer to reroute the pieces to get
this knight to a better circuit
also as mentioned this white king how do
you get it to safety it is
kind of an end game not quite an end
game because the queens are off uh but
still this king might come under fire if
it stays in the center for too long
black has simple plans black and
centralize the rooks maybe even try and
break out in the center at some point
just to uh
just to try and create some imbalance as
you mentioned simon yeah i mean i i
guess one of the hardest things to do in
chess is is to play for a draw and
i this is i i imagine a bit different
from magnus because he's had so much
experience in this but historically um
if you know you need a draw and it
doesn't matter what color you are even
if you've got the white pieces it's
really hard to suddenly
change and have that in mind you should
actually play for a win right if you
need to if you need to get a draw you
should play your normal stuff and try to
actually win the game i mean there's
been cases where
the famous one gurovich with the white
pieces um in the run-up to an old world
championships matches playing nigel
shorts and he played the exchange french
and just tried to draw and he lost very
convincingly uh against nigel short and
that's i think the same
series where nigel short went on to to
face gary kasparov um in in the final so
it it's kind of challenging to have to
play for a draw especially for someone
like me because i had no idea how to do
that in normal chess anyway and i'd
really struggle but it's um magnus you
know he can't relax here uh too much if
he wants to get a result but
i still don't see too many problems of
his position to be to be honest here i
don't i don't think the computer is i
think the computer's been very
optimistic uh about vladimir wow look at
that i mean it's giving vlad herself a
major advantage why i don't i don't
i think it's
isn't it being optimistic here or too
enthusiastic
and it kind of links in quite nicely
with hugo bushman's question
who asks with the queens of the board
isn't your king meant to be safe in the
center yep usually but here every single
other piece is still on the board and
you could imagine maybe a line opening
up for example if the d-file ever opens
up that could push some pawns
white king
i mean it looks pretty safe to be honest
but there is some hint of a potential
attack against it and it might feel
vulnerable while the rooks remain at
least so end games you're completely
right there hugo kings in the center
they tend to be more flexible um
and usually that's where you want them
but maybe here it's an exception um
magnus will hope that he can get the
rooks off at some point and then the
white king will feel completely safe
yeah this is one of those things i think
it was in one of john nunn's books he
calls it uh is it an nq
e or something like that it's not quite
an end game because there's still too
many pieces left on the board okay
meanwhile look at this white's knight i
highlighted it as a bad piece because it
was dominated by porn magnus steps it
back and he's going to actually plant it
in front of his king to act as a
defender so it still looks alright
doesn't it i mean it looks solid enough
for now at least for white talking about
john nunn books did you
ever get the book secrets of porn lists
and people just peaceless endings yeah
it's been a few years since i read it i
must admit but i did uh
that was actually a trick it was porn oh
it's not i was
i said porn listen peaceless i was just
feeding silly there because apparently
it was an advert there's one of
peaceless endings peaceless and exactly
one thing yeah yeah i think it was a
joke someone said pointless okay yeah
you tricked me with the word
the peaceless one i've read i think
someone put an advert into one of the
magazines and they advertised this book
the secrets of pawnless and peaceless
endings which is just like an empty
board right but then loads of people
pre-ordered this book so sorry i'm sorry
it's really i'm sorry i'm sorry i'll buy
you a drink laser dave
but no he's just no way that will cost
you yeah yeah you know that there on
that subject of uh there was a i think
it was john nunn he wrote a book about
rick and porn endings and it dealt with
pawns on the a b c d
files so we'll be basically the left
side of the board and a reader wrote in
and he goes this book is a complete con
because it didn't cover e f g h
forgetting that of course whatever is
relevant
on the left side is going to be
irrelevant on the other side of the
board as well that's a good point
actually yeah
i have to say those books i know they've
won awards i'm i i couldn't get my head
around them because it was just
lines and lines and i was like i just
can't it wasn't they weren't for me they
were great books obviously because
they they got very good reviews but they
they weren't weren't for me yeah you
have to be a certain level i guess for
those uh books and there are definitely
i mean there are books out there there
are video courses which are maybe more
wordy with more explanations yeah right
um maybe i think
magnus is that one isn't he i mean for
chess baller of course with john
bartholomew i think on on
some some great in-game course which is
the fundamentals of
the hundred hundred and games you need
that's right and that that is a great
book and a great course magnus teaching
you endings we've seen how seen how good
he is at that so
magnus stepping up his pawn and what i
like about this move is that this pawn
move it's small but it does control the
squares of the black knight sitting on
f6 look at the computer though what's
the computer doing today does it it's
it's gone has gone psycho yeah
it hates why it's positional doesn't it
it's literally saying is that i can't is
it over a porn advantage nearly two porn
advantages in black is that real
i why why
i mean uh i mean black's pieces are all
better than white's pieces but just yeah
i mean i hear if you made me guess i
would say maybe 0.5 but then yeah you're
right simon to say nearly plus two yeah
yeah that seems excessive and magnus
only needs a draw but also look at the
clock for vladislav artemyev down to two
minutes
is that enough to get that win that he
needs
he needs ten minutes more i feel
in order to put any pressure on white's
position you have to be super accurate
which computers are maybe that's why
they see the black cattle advantage
their horizon is quite deep and they
always find the most incisive most
challenging moves so maybe black does
have an objective advantage but with two
minutes on the clock against the world
champion who's an end game expert it's
gonna be hard to prove that and white
also doesn't have any weaknesses that's
maybe why we're most surprised um if you
look at white's half of the board he's
controlled most of the squares there
black still needs to do a bit of dancing
around a bit of organization work in
order to actually creep into white's
half so
um yeah it does feel like okay with this
last move at least creating a threat
maybe
but magnus stops that black was trying
to push a pawn forward and the e file to
open up the center to go for that white
king in the middle but magnus trying to
shut down that idea
okay interesting seems very optimistic
view from the computer but just for me
because there's not many open lines
normally when an advantage is secure
it's because you've got some open lines
an attack or some big big gain in the
position which is very hard for human to
see but
it doesn't look like vladislav is really
finding any advantage at the moment with
the way he's playing no and this is uh
this is the type of position where i can
easily see um a club player for instance
taking a draw because they say okay well
you know all the piece minor pieces are
on the board there's only one open line
pawn structure is relatively similar
why not and uh
but this type of position with all four
minor pieces on the board you kind of
you get the idea of exchanging pieces
like when is a good time to exchange and
this is something that edson mito asks i
would like to know what's the best time
to exchange pieces in chess i'm learning
chas and he's from mozambique
nice and uh here we go talking about
exchanges
here
is one at least plaque's trying to open
it up yeah with this move i guess he has
to try something right yeah in order to
win this game yeah uh the moment was
about to pass so he's trying to open
things up objectively maybe nothing but
um there we go some trades and black
will maybe gain the bishop pair
uh to answer that question about
exchanges i remember i think it was
yes serejuana was it maurice ashley who
said it was the two fs you should go for
exchanges if they're forced
or fantastic there was another f as well
maybe but either way if the exchanges
are forced here black is exchanging
pieces because he's in a must-win
situation but usually a fourth situation
would be to stop checkmate uh to maybe
get rid of one of your opponent's strong
pieces or if it's fantastic where you
trade off maybe your bad piece for your
opponent's strong piece then you go for
trades but don't go for exchanges just
because you think it will guide you to
safety i think that's the key
because often players spend three or
four moves going for a trade and
actually they
they need those moves later on so yeah
yeah exchanging pieces it's actually one
of the hardest things or knowing when to
it's one of the hardest things in chess
i guess you've got to see the potential
in the pieces as well because sometimes
you can exchange off your piece um for
one of your opponents pieces but not
realizing that it can maneuver better
than your opponent's pieces so the long
long term prospects of your pieces as
well
i guess is important yeah and talking of
exchanges stockfish now the computer
thinks that white only has one move to
keep the balance and that involves an
exchange and this is a good example
actually white's best move is to use his
dark square bishop and capture that
black knight in the center of the board
that's just a trade uh bishop and knight
worth roughly the same but black's
knight is fantastic here it's a great
piece threatening to jump in with a
nasty check starting to jump in maybe to
attack white's rook at the bottom of the
board it's just too strong a piece so
that's when to go for a trade when your
opponent has a piece that is too strong
and magnus goes for it that knight could
not be allowed to survive and uh now
black has the bishop pair but black does
have a weak isolated pawn in the center
of the board so yeah we saw there the
computer suggestions magnus finding the
best move by far but he can get there by
process of elimination and uh this
exchange
does allow as well white knight at the
white knight to plant itself in the
middle of the board later yeah i guess
it's just one trick isn't there yeah
in this position after black recaptures
with a bishop you you you don't want to
okay he's got he's gone this way first
but you have to be careful when you
plonk your uh knight into the center of
the board
as we'll see in a second yep so white
will recapture that rook
most likely with his own rook and yeah
knight jumping into the center is not a
good move yet i think but you can you
can just prepare that move yeah um shall
we show this because it's the final
maybe critical moment in this game
white's knight wants to occupy this
square and he wants to plant it there
over the next few turns but if you do it
now after bishop takes another trade
this is what i meant by four-star
fantastic this is fantastic for black
because everything's level but there's a
nasty follow-up there's a check
supported by this bishop and this is
actually a double attack when the white
king moves the white bishop drops off
and black would be a piece up that's why
magnus prepares this knight jump by just
moving his rook forward
and everything's defended now for white
if black just takes a timeout for
example moose the king now you can go
for this night jump because after this
exchange after this trade there's a
check but white's king can just move and
now the white rook defends everything
this would actually lead to a dead drawn
end game and uh talking of dead draw
name games we're heading towards one but
artemis does have a trick in mind
and in this position he traded off the
white knight before it landed on that
central square and now utilizing a pin
on this file against the white king he
is attacking white's pawn in the middle
here but this shouldn't really be enough
white can just step this pawn forward i
think
and it's a bit ugly for white after this
trade you do get left with an isolated
pawn which your bishop has to
stay and defend but everything
everything else is balanced if the rooks
come off it's simply a dead draw with
opposite colour bishops just kind of
passing each other not making any effect
on each other
and uh yeah still some work for magnus
to be done maybe
yeah at least black can play this
position on for a long long time just
just uh try trying to bring the king and
that and that ending you said and just
try to make some improvements but i
can't imagine magnus would ever lose
that position yeah um so
now and but the great thing about this
position for artemiev and again i've
been a bit enthusiastic with my word
great is that okay you know he's only
got one minute on the clock and it's the
type of position where you can just make
moves at tempo you can make them quickly
and build up that time because
one minute against magnus is eight
that's going to
be very difficult actually
and it's an opposite color bishop and
end game and we have a very interesting
question from
hey well let me bring up my document uh
from costa from costas who asks you ask
us how many moves ahead does a super
grand master normally count
good question it's far fewer than you
would think
um yeah i think in tv shows and media
they always assume super grandmasters
are working 20 30 moves ahead but it's
never that way really it's normally
maybe
in two or three directions it's three or
four on average but
yeah i don't think you need to calculate
ahead in most positions in end games
where every move really matters then you
look even further ahead or if every move
is forced for both sides it's easier to
look into the distance but if there are
different branches what's the point
looking 10 moves ahead in one line when
actually there are three or four other
lines to look at as well so i think
grandmasters the trick is they just know
where to look they know what direction
to look in yeah simon i think there's
like a great way you can learn that
skill as well because that's obviously a
very important skill to try and learn
just
visual visualization you say just being
able to visualize how things turn up and
i'd say start with endings a lot of
people look at tactics when there's like
loads of pieces on the board but if you
start by just king and pawn endings it
means you only have a couple of branches
possibilities that you should be
analyzing so you can really visualize a
long way ahead if there's not many
pieces on the board so if you get some
king and pawn
ending puzzles and there's probably
loads of literature out there you can do
it's a great way to improve your
visualization rather than trying to
calculate immensely complicated
positions where there's hundreds of
pieces in the box you'll just get
confused and you can add pieces on
as you try to calculate that's what i
recommend you do if you if you want to
improve your your visualization yeah
that's a great tip because if for
example you're doing night 10 games it's
just a night and it's important you work
out more about what the knight wants
where it wants to be how flexible it is
and uh the night's path and then you add
pieces as you master each
you master bishops you must have knights
and slowly from there you look like you
look of course that doesn't has anyone
done that yeah that could be a good that
could be a good set at that one so yeah
yeah you're the adjustable expert here
simon yeah get it we'll get it done for
chessable and uh meanwhile magnus just
relocating the white bishop white's
bishop actually stood terribly a few
moves ago now it's a great piece and
no imbalances here apart from white
having an isolated pawn in the middle of
the board but it's well defended and
white's king active
i think this last move shows artemyev
knows he's not going to get anywhere
yeah and uh this one is fizzling out to
a draw if the rooks come off magnus is
through to the final it's going to be a
draw i must admit i actually thought
that magnus would offer a trade of rooks
i didn't expect him to push that pawn
forward
and artemia definitely trying you know
advancing some pawns
you know he is counting on the powerful
dark square bishop he has in the middle
of the board for 20 seconds the promise
now white's rook's on an open file and
black rook is a bit blocked by the white
bishop
and uh yeah things are getting hot on
the board
also very warming
yes uh home office as we're used to
seeing by now 26 degrees wow
under 10 seconds okay he's just made his
move
just shuffling the rook across doesn't
really improve anything for black
magnus just put everything on light
squares now
away from the eye line of the black
bishop and
i don't see any plan to be honest for
black unfortunately
and i'll tell you if he's just making
moves but he's down to 10 20 seconds
every time he moves now it's going to be
difficult to create anything for him
he's got this uh h4 push at some at some
stage you're trying to open up the range
of his bishop well he did until until
magnus plays it first and uh shutting
him down yeah
and now the white rook can even jump
into the position
i'm struggling to see how the black
there we go the white rook does enter
not threatening anything but just
showing that compared to the black rook
it is the more active piece maybe
can artemia have kind of put all his
hopes on creating a past pawn against on
the right side of the board
he has a three versus two majority there
possibly maybe long term but it's
difficult to arrange and that would
uh also require some help from magnus
magnus meanwhile just going after some
black pawns and he's gonna try and
repeat the position the black bishop
meanwhile we've actually seen this
position but earlier it was black to
play now it's white to play
just
a bit of fun and games there just
magnus magnus got a sneaky threat he
wants to offer a trade of rooks
and force those rooks off the board
which would be a hundred percent draw
yeah i mean trying to win this position
against the best in-game player of all
time
it's a little tricky right it's a big
struggle it's an uphill struggle so
definitely
okay the black rook trying to get active
but white shuts that down again with his
bishop and no progress to be to be made
whatever black tries white just says no
hang on you could be a bit sneaky right
could you offer up one pawn you could
push the a pawn one square and your
whole idea is just to break could have
been captured it could be a draw it's a
draw yes there could be okay we do see a
result magnus is through to the finals
yes
after only three games in this
semi-final as well magnus winning game
one and game two is ready for the first
final in the milton champions chess tour
2022